Okay, so welcome back to the computer
screen. What we're going to have a look at
now is a sensible and typical trading plan
for a beginner taking this professional
trading approach.
So we're going to use the example here
that we've already skimmed over in the
portfolio management section, the
portfolio parameter construction measures.
And we're going to set up a theoretical
margin account here with $25,000 deposited
on margin.
And as ever, we do want to give ourselves
a chance of making money.
So we're going to be setting gross
exposure limits so we don't actually ever
receive a margin call from our broker.
And we're looking here at a typical
situation in Europe where we're trading
leveraged CFDs.
And in the equities space, we're looking
at five times exposure rate, assuming a
well diversified longshore portfolio.
And also with currencies, an exposure rate
of between six to eight times and
commodities four to five times.
In the United States, things may be a
little bit different.
So just make sure with your broker what
your exposure rates can and can't be.
But typically, professional traders may
take an approach of five times equity
exposure, six to eight times currencies
and four to five times on commodities.
So really, to get up to that point, you've
got to be making some money first.
So we're applying this principle that
professional traders always apply, that
when we're losing money, we reduce
exposure because we don't have the right
to continue running the same amount of
capital as before.
But as we're winning, as we're making
money, we seek to increase our exposure
rates as we've got the right to commit
more capital.
So we're just going to go through this
example here where we've got $25,000
deposited on margin.
Really, the minimum amount of capital you
can use to take this approach is around
15,000 US dollars.
Below these levels, the amount of exposure
and the diversity that you need to take is
just not really possible.
Your risk will become too concentrated and
your position sizes, if you wanted to be
diverse, would just be too small.
So we're looking at $25,000 here and the
minimum is really $15,000.
You know, we don't pretend here that you
can open a trading account with $1,000 and
go 10 times leveraged in equities and 100
times leveraged in Forex.
We really just don't advocate that because
that's the typical retail to trader
strategy.
Unfortunately, there is, if you want to
take the professional approach, a kind of
minimum barrier to entry in terms of
capital required.
So the minimum is $15,000 and here we're
going to use the example of $25,000.
And we're going to assume as well a 5%
return before we increase our exposure
rate.
So this may be over a couple of months
because we're using the one to three
months investment horizon, trading horizon
on all our positions.
So in step one, we're looking at $100,000
exposure across eight to 10 positions,
which means we're four times exposed on
our $25,000 that's been deposited.
If we're four times exposed, that means
we've got a 25% cushion, which means we
can lose 25% before we receive a margin
call.
However, if we're running a long, short,
diverse portfolio of eight to 10
positions, this is very, very hard to
achieve.
So this gives us a lot of comfort in terms
of not being stopped out or receiving a
margin call when we take our first step in
trading.
Now, if we manage to make a 5% return on
our $100,000 over the first few months,
that means our trading account will have
exposure of 105 because our margin has
increased now from 25 to 30,000.
And then we're increasing our exposure
rate up to five times because now we've
got the right to commit more capital, as
in take more exposure.
However, at the same time, we are actually
increasing our positioning, our positions
to 10 to 12 positions in the portfolio.
Meaning that even though we're increasing
our exposure, we are actually increasing
our diversity.
So our risk may not actually be going up,
even though we're making money and our
exposure is higher.
The five times exposure rate gives us a
20% cushion rather than a 25% cushion on
four times exposure.
However, we are more diverse.
So as our exposure rates go up, what
you're going to find is that your P&L
swings will go up slightly, but you will
actually be more diverse.
Then in step two, when we've got our
150,000 exposure and our margin of 30K, if
we assume a 5% return after another few
months.
So now let's assume that we've been
trading a total of say four to six months.
This is a sensible target in terms of
making another 5% and then your margin
increases to 37,500 US dollars.
And at this stage, we can really look to
start taking some risk here, where we
increase our exposure to six times what we
have deposited on margin, which means we
have $225,000 exposure.
And at the same time, we again increase
the amount of positions in our portfolio
to increase diversity.
And remember that the entire time that
this is happening, we are sticking to our
principles of risk management and our
principles of trading psychology.
So as we're increasing our exposure in
terms of psychology, we're attempting to
cut our losers and increase our winning
trades and replace them with fresh ideas
and also overlaying our portfolio.
So our 8 to 10 positions, our 10 to 12 and
our 12 to 14 positions overlaying each of
these portfolios with sensible risk
management parameters.
So if we look at the typical example here,
when we start out, a typical example here
may be the $100,000 portfolio, which we've
explained here, across 10 positions in
equities.
Now, at the moment, there's no hard and
fast rule here.
You can have some commodities exposure.
You can have some currencies exposure.
But to get used to this idea of building
portfolios around spread trades and
themes, this is a sensible approach to
take to begin with.
So you're looking at an exposure of 50,000
on the long side, 50,000 on the short
side.
You can be beta hedged if you want.
That's totally fine.
But a gross exposure limit of 100,000
across 10 positions.
So five longs and five shorts with a
restriction on your net exposure, your net
positioning to market risk.
And what you can do here is actually when
you start out, because when you start out,
you will just have zero exposure in your
portfolio, is build the portfolio in two
stages.
So build each position in two stages by
taking a $5,000 position now and then a
$5,000 position later, given the
opportunities to get a better price or
prices on a breakout of the spreads.
In terms of overlaying your portfolios
with sensible risk management parameters,
we've seen a lot of them already, but
let's run through some of the basics here
again.
What you may want to do here, and by the
way, this spreadsheet is available in the
downloads area.
What you may want to do here is have a
restriction on your net positioning.
So here in this mini portfolio, the
restriction is 35% net long or short
exposure.
I would say a sensible approach when
you're starting out is to just have a
maximum of net long or short exposure, a
limit of 50%.
Moving on to stop losses and targets.
Remember, every stop loss is a hard stop
loss.
You can't automatically set them in your
brokerage account because we're doing our
stop losses on spreads.
And our hard stop losses on large cap and
mid cap spreads are somewhere between 7%
to 12%, meaning that our soft targets are
21% to 36%.
So you should apply this 1 to 3 rule on
your spread trades across your portfolio.
Also, you should apply and overlay really
a portfolio stop loss of about 10% on your
exposure.
So in our example that we've just been
through, $10,000 on your exposure in step
1 of $100,000 is really your stop loss on
your whole portfolio.
So if you lose $10,000 of your original
$25,000, then you've got $15,000 left.
You can live to fight another day and you
just start again.
You take a break, take a break from
trading for a couple of months and then
seek to build your watch list again, build
out your ideas and then begin again.
You never ever want to receive a margin
call.
So make sure you overlay your portfolio
with a stop loss on the entire portfolio.
And what will happen is because you've got
8 to 10 positions and you're putting a 7%
to 12% stop loss on all of your positions,
for this to actually occur, it means that
you'd have to get all of your spread
trades wrong, which is pretty unlikely.
So if all of your spread trades hit, say,
your 10% stop losses between 7% and 12%,
then you're just going to be stopped at.
And if you get every single spread trade
wrong, when you've got 8 to 10 positions,
so 4 to 5 spread trades,
if you get every single spread trade
wrong, then there's clearly something
drastically wrong.
So you should stop yourself out of your
whole portfolio.
You can, of course, beat a hedge where you
want to.
So if you want to take a little bit of
market risk, that's okay.
But just go through the beta exercises and
make sure that you've got the risk that
you want on
and the risk that you want to hedge out
hedged out.
You should probably be seeking to get a
mix of cross-sector, cross-sector
constituent and intra-sector constituent
spread trades.
Just try them out.
It's all about experimentation in the
beginning.
So you don't have to go huge in all of
your trades.
Like I said, you can have starter
positions and seek to build out the trades
as you get better prices or on breakouts.
Because on breakouts, they'll be winning
trades already.
So you can seek to add to any of these
trades.
If you're going to do cross-currency
spread trades, it's probably not the best
thing to do to begin with.
But as you're growing and you do
cross-currency spread trades, if you don't
want the currency risk, make sure you
begin by hedging out the currency risk.
So you do the three trades that we talked
about in the example for hedging out
cross-currency spread trade currency risk.
And as you're making money, as you're
going from step one to step two and to
step three over the first six months, when
you're making money, you can seek to
increase your exposure rates.
Make sure you're increasing your diversity
and not concentrating your risk.
And also, you may seek to take positions
in currencies that you actually have a
view on.
So this is very different to hedging out
the currency risk on a spread trade.
Because if you have no view on the
currency, you should just hedge it out.
But if you do have a view on the currency,
you can take, as you're growing, positions
in currencies.
And remember, they're going to be less
volatile than equities.
And you can take positions in commodities.
This will help you as a trader develop
over the medium to longer term, where you
can have exposure in different asset
classes.
And when you're taking currency exposure,
as a rule of thumb, try to restrict your
currency positioning exposure to the size
of your equities exposure in your trading
account.
But still take a one to three month view.
So what do we mean by that?
Well, let's say you're in step two.
And you've got $150,000 in exposure in
your portfolio in terms of equities
exposure.
Then if you're going to take currency
positions, try to restrict them to
$150,000.
So don't go over the amount of your
equities exposure when you're taking
currencies exposure.
And currencies, we've seen already, are a
lot less volatile than equities as a rule,
as a general rule across the board, across
the major currency pairs.
So that type of exposure is about right
for beginners.
So what you will see if you've got a
margin trading account and your broker,
for example, allows you to take a hundred
times exposure.
Well, what you will see is that you're
actually just utilizing a very small
amount of your margin when you restrict
yourself to that size.
And then if and when these currency
positions actually make money and become
winning trades, then they become an option
to seek more risk.
So start off with no more than the
equities exposure, the corresponding
equities exposure in your portfolio.
No more exposure than that in a currency
position as a starter position.
Remember the whole time we want to be
pulling from box A when getting paid and
pulling from box B when paying out.
But we need to make sure that we're
cutting our losing trades, making sure
that we don't take more exposure there.
And when we're getting paid, make sure
that we're pulling from box A and looking
to run our winning positions, not take
profits.
Run your winning positions and actually
seek more risk.
And in terms of recycling, well, you're
always going to have a portfolio and
you're going to be running your winners
and cutting your losers.
Your ideas from your watch list have to
replace your losers.
So make sure that you're always
maintaining this watch list every week.
Every week you should probably look at
between 8 to 12 hours per week.
This can be done with a full time job.
8 to 12 hours per week.
Maybe 3 to 4 hours on a Wednesday evening.
3 to 4 hours on a Saturday or Sunday
morning.
So you're prepared for the week.
Updating all of your spreads.
Generating new, fresh trading ideas.
And a couple of hours during the week
you'll be going into your trading account
as well.
You know, just to check up on things.
You don't need to be trading every day.
Your time horizon here is 1 to 3 months.
And everything should be reviewed on a
week to week basis.
So a couple of hours during the week
you'll be going into your trading account.
In total a few hours to check things
through.
Maybe just 10 minutes every day.
And on a Wednesday evening budget 3 to 4
hours.
So you can update your watch list.
Check on the spreads.
Make sure your losers aren't losing too
much money.
Or hitting your stop losses.
So you can trade out to them if you need
to.
Running your winners.
Possibly adding to them.
And then doing the same on a Saturday or
Sunday.
Planning for the Monday.
Make sure your ideas are fresh and
current.
If something's been on your watch list for
a very, very long time.
Then you should probably be seeking to
actually take it off the watch list and
replace it with new ideas.
A long time maybe 2 or 3 months.
It doesn't mean it's a bad idea.
It just means it could be a stale idea.
Or you're just far too early.
It's going to have to be your call.
There's no rules here.
So just try and maintain a fresh and
current updated watch list.
And stick to the plan.
You know, stick to these.
Stick to this investment process.
Stick to the trading process.
Make sure your ideas are current.
Always maintain your world view.
Make sure you're always up to date with
the leading indicators.
With modern technology, you can set
yourself up to receive alerts on your
telephone.
You can get feeds into your email.
It's all very easy to keep on top of.
Once you've learned what the leading
indicators actually mean.
And how you can use them and interpret
them to make money.
To make real hard dollars in your
portfolio.
Make sure your watch list is always
updated in the gatekeeping process.
Stay away from bad ideas.
Keep good ideas on your watch list.
As in ideas that are making money.
And making money consistently.
But try to time them right.
Get the technical analysis and the price
action right.
Make sure when you're looking at your
opportunities.
That your risk management is outlined
correctly.
Always have a look at the distribution and
the ATR.
Check the historical volatility.
Make sure the opportunity is actually
there to make money.
And in risk management.
Make sure that your stop losses are
sensible.
And your targets are actually sensible and
realistic.
And make sure that you're overlaying your
portfolio.
With sensible risk management parameters.
And last but not least.
The Kelly criterion.
Make sure you're putting all your trades
in the Kelly criterion.
And making sure that you do this
separately.
In your portfolio management Kelly
criterion.
And your short term day trading Kelly
In terms of monitoring volatility.
Definitely keep on top of the implied
volatility indicators in the market.
Make sure you're watching the VIX in the
United States.
Make sure you're watching the V stocks on
the Eurostox 600.
Make sure you're watching the VDAX in
Germany.
And the V FTSE in the United Kingdom.
If you see these implied volatility
indicators going up sharply.
You've got to consider doing something.
We've been through this quite a few times
now.
And you just don't want to be the rabbit
in the headlights.
Make sure that you're thinking or
considering of doing something.
That's a good idea.
And probably the best thing to do.
If you do actually want to transition.
And remember there's no rule book here.
You just have to make a sensible call.
If you don't feel comfortable.
Probably the best thing to do.
In terms of transitioning.
Just to make sure that you're doing
something.
Is to trade out of your losers first.
So just go into your portfolio.
Trade out your losers.
Raise some cash.
And that will enable you to short term
trade.
In terms of the Kelly criterion.
We've just been through it.
Make sure that you keep a separate Kelly
criterion.
For your portfolio trading.
And your short term or day trading.
Always monitor your W and R.
And make sure every 10 to 20 trades.
You're keeping on top of your W and R.
And seeing if you're becoming a worse or a
better trader.
Make sure you do quarterly reviews.
And make sure you do annual reviews of
your case score.
Your W and your R.
And in those periods.
Ask yourself.
Whether you should be adding.
Or taking away.
Money from your trading account.
As in seeking more risk.
When you're winning.
And seeking less risk.
When you're losing.
And that ladies and gentlemen.
Is pretty much it.
That is a typical.
Example of how you should set out.
Taking the professional.
Trading approach.
Keep a winning mentality.
Remember.
A winning mentality.
Is not to go out.
And seek lots of risk.
And try to become rich quick.
Keeping a winning mentality.
The winning mentality.
Is actually.
Seeking to become wealthy.
From trading.
Over time.
And having consistent returns.
Over your entire lifetime.
Until retirement.
Stay humble.
Make sure.
That you let the market.
Tell you what to do.
And don't allow.
Don't allow yourself.
To tell the market.
What's possible.
The market's bigger than you.
It's smarter than you.
Just stay humble.
And good luck.
With your trading.
I wish you the best of luck.
This isn't an easy game.
But once you're on top of this process.
This is the best process.
For you.
As a beginner.
As a retail trader.
To go out.
And take the professional approach.
You'll stand a lot.
Higher chance.
Of making money.
Consistently.
Over your lifetime.
By taking this approach.
I hope you enjoyed it.
Good luck.
And keep trading.
you